I think I now finally am beginning to
understand quantum mechanics today on
the into the impossible podcast we
welcome for the third time the
world-renowned computer scientist Dr
Steven wolf Steven's been responsible
for many breakthroughs in computer
science including many inventions that
you may even have on your phone right
now he's been a Pioneer in developing
and applying computational thinking
going as far as to develop his own
programming language computational
reducibility says you can't cheat the
passage of time most recently he claims
to have some the mystery behind the most
perplexing law of nature the second law
of Thermodynamics and it's doing all the
things that the second or of
thermodynamic says you shouldn't be able
to do tune in and find out if you agree
that Stevens unlocked the mysteries of
the thermodynamic Universe today he's
here to prove what many who have come
before him have failed to do and along
the way we'll go into a fascinating
journey in the dark side of the universe
a way that only Steven wol from and I
can take you so let's tune in well
welcome everybody to the third round of
my
conversational uh inter dialogization
with this uh phenomenal guest today this
is Steph Wolfram as I say third third
time guest on the podcast uh Dr Steph
Wolfram joining us from the East Coast
how are you tonight Stephen just fine
it's late for for for me so it's even
later for you I really appreciate you
staying up so late on the E I'm a I'm a
late
worker you're a night owl of my day you
were on first time three years ago when
I first started the podcast and in the
intervening three years since we've had
our conversation you have written many
books but the two books that have really
piqu my interest and millions of people
around the world are the books you wrote
this year and those are what is GPT
doing and we'll talk about that uh
briefly and we'll talk primarily I
believe about the second law and you're
kind lots of things you know I realized
you you you said you want to talk about
these books so I went to my bookshelf
and I realized this is my um that's
those are the books that I wrote during
the pandemic it's kind of a a big pile
it is some no it's very productive I'm
I'm impressed with myself I think uh
yeah I think my audience will want to
know are you writing a book as we speak
with one of your hands it would not
surprise me but Stephen since you came
on three years ago I added a new segment
on the podcast called judging books by
their covers and so I'd like you to take
uh either one of the book let's start
with the chat GPT book maybe and I want
you to explain uh the cover title the
design and uh the any of the artwork yes
so can you please explain what gave you
the idea for the title and cover I wrote
this little book because chpt came out I
know something about these kinds of
things and lots of people asked what is
chat GPT doing and why does it work so I
decided to write a book with that title
and actually it was originally a Blog
post and then then a chap I know
actually the person called Paul Graham
who's the founder of white combinator
sent me mail saying you know this was
really good blog post you should turn it
into a book and I I said it's too small
to be a book it's uh uh it's too short
they us should turn into a book anyway
so we so I told my publishing team we're
going to make a book in the next couple
of weeks this was a book made very
quickly it was uh you know it's it's
about what it says you know what is chat
gb2 doing does it work this kind of
large scale overview of of
uh how an AI system like this works it's
was rather easy for me to write I it
took me a very short amount of time to
write this but it's something which
still I I believe it's really quite
unique and a lot of people read it um in
both particularly in the in the
technology world uh sort of the the
execs in the technology World widely
read by by those people uh kind of a a
you know it's it's kind of the the high
level overview of uh of what chat GPT is
doing and the question that I was really
interested in is why does it work and
that's really a a thing that I realized
that it's really telling us a science
fact it's telling us human language
which is sort of a pinnacle of our
achievement is in some sense not as
complicated as we thought there are
regularities in human language which
chat gbt the llm this the large language
model discovered
that we kind of should have known we're
there for the last couple of thousand
years but we didn't you know we kind of
knew that that language was made up in
kind of sentences that went you know
noun verb noun and so on but what chat
gbt and so on is is showing us is
something about the kind of the further
structure the kind of the way that you
put together sentences based on the the
kinds of combinations of words that can
mean things and and the cover in this
particular case is a is a piece of the
inerts of um uh of chat gbt showing kind
of the the flow of information through
the neural net that uh is the it's kind
of it's this neural net is kind of like
a giant mathematical function with a in
the case of of chat gbt hundreds of
billions of parameters and you feed in a
piece of text that you've given so far
and out comes its statement of what it
thinks the next word should be in the
piece of text that you're generating
actually it's kind of fun to see the the
you know we we uh the translations of
this book into different languages have
lots of different covers including some
very wild no doubt AI generated covers
that um I kind of wonder what the prompt
was um that led to those led to those
covers try to reverse engineer The
Prompt yeah I'm always worried about you
know they had mad cow disease back in
the 90s and now that Bots are training
other Bots I'm kind of worried about mad
bot disease but maybe we'll get into
that after you describe the uh the
second law book that really has
captivated me and I have a lot of
questions not only just from me but for
my audience is dying to ask you
questions and I've taken some on Twitter
and from YouTube comment section so
explain what we're looking at there the
second law right right right so I mean
and you know what's what's this cover
has an interesting story okay so it
begins 51 years ago so I was a
12-year-old kid and I'd gotten
interested in physics i' originally been
interested in space but um that kind of
segwayed into an interest in physics and
I'd been you know starting to read
physics books and so on and I was
graduating from English Elementary
School more or less as that's the
English system that's sort of an age1 12
thing and I kind of the as a sort of
pseudo graduation gift I suppose that
translated into modern American culture
would be I'm I'm going to get these
these books and there was a series of
five books about physics uh the actually
the Berkeley Physics course series
undergraduate physics textbook series
and so I got these books and um uh it
was in June of
1972 and uh I kind of in those days I
used to write my name and the date when
I got books and the books I stopped
doing that at some point which was a
shame but so I I kind of know when I got
these books so it turns out that book
well the the the fifth book in that
series was about statistical physics was
about kind of the physics of systems
that have so many components you have to
use statistics to say how they work so
for example molecules in a gas things
like this and the cover of that book if
I can uh can hold up that's um that's
the uh book cover that that um um that
show was that Kel in was that a Kel book
or yes that's that's that's um the
person who made that cover was a trap
called Bernie aler and uh R Fred R was
the guy who wrote the book but it was It
was kind of connected with catel and and
and that whole crowd that book cover was
kind of a claimed to be a simulation of
kind of gas molecules in a box starting
off in this kind of very on one side of
the box kind of ordered on one side of
the box and then progressively with time
becoming more disordered and eventually
kind of randomly filling the box and
that was uh was kind of a a thing that
was sort of a core feature of
statistical physics the second law of
Thermodynamics the LW of entropy
increase and so on Illustrated on this
on this book cover I got really
interested in this partly because this
was a case where the book was claiming
you could derive a law of physics from
not just be told oh relativity works or
uh quantum mechanics works it was you
can actually derive the law of physics
from something that is more fundamental
just something essentially mathematical
something formal you could derive this
law of physics this law of entropy
increase this idea that things tend to
get more random over time I thought that
was pretty interesting uh I didn't fully
at that time at age 12 or whatever I
don't think I fully understood the math
that was in this book and I didn't fully
believe it actually and I said I'm going
to simulate this this thing that's on
this book cover and at that time I had
access to a computer very primitive
computer by today's standards it was
about the size of a large desk and it
was you know programmed with paper tape
things like this and I'm like I'm going
to simulate this thing and see whether I
can get the same results as are on the
book cover well I didn't succeed and you
know as it turns out years later I
realize the fact that I didn't succeed
was actually showing me something very
interesting but at the time I kind of
wasn't ready to understand that point
anyway so the the end result of that I
was interested in the second law of
Thermodynamics second law of
Thermodynamics has this funny history
you know it was It was kind of first
mentioned in the 1820s and then kind of
really uh people started talking a lot
about it in the 1860s
and people said well you know we're not
even sure molecules exist so the second
law of Thermodynamics is about sort of
randomization of molecules we don't even
know molecules exist and so it was all
very confused and uh by the beginning of
the 1900s when people realized molecules
do exist it was kind of like oh and by
the way the second law was proved
mathematically back in the past well it
never had been and this led to many
confusions over the years of people
saying you know is the second law really
true is it you know what what is the
cause of it how does it work we can talk
about this more or Stephen how about how
about this quote from your fellow
Countryman Sir Arthur Edington he said
uh in 1915 the year of Einstein's you
know one of his Miracle years if your
theory is found to be against the second
law of Thermodynamics I can give you no
hope there is nothing for it to collapse
in deepest humiliation and yet you're
right nobody had proven it I think by
that point right I mean that it was so I
know nobody the the stuff I've done
recently is the closest we've got to
kind of proving the second world of
thermodynamics and understanding what
its real Origins are yes I I'm not I was
never very impressed with Edington I
have to say and uh that was not you know
I'm I'm aware of that quote I mean you
know in in fact in the in this book one
part of the book is devoted to my
efforts to trace the history of the
Second World of thermodynamics which I I
have to say I was very surprised nobody
had written a definitive history of the
Second World of ther Dynamics after I
worked on it I understood why they
hadn't it's really complicated and you
have to know a whole bunch of stuff
about kind of the technical side of
what's going on to be able to untangle
what's happening but yeah Edington was a
late stage person because really by the
beginning of the 20th century people had
sort of said we know the second war is
true actually I'll tell you a story
about about the second law and and
proving the second law so you know
Einstein you mentioned 1915 General Al
1905 was Einstein's kind of miracle year
where he introduced you know photons and
he introduced uh kind of a brownan
motion that proved molecules existed and
relativity okay so big big year okay so
I was studying the second law and I was
interested in who had worked on trying
to prove the second law well it turns
out one name I didn't know was going to
be on there is Albert Einstein So In
1902 1903 1904 he wrote three papers
they were all on the second law and they
all purported to be essentially proofs
of the second law and they were all
wrong he had actually been working on
the second law right up to to the time
when and he never worked on the second
law again after
1905 but what was really interesting to
me was the kind of thinking that went
into his attempts to prove the second
law was this kind of philosophical way
of thinking about science that he kind
of got a little bit from boltzman
boltzman had been the person who had who
had um uh been um uh very much involved
in kind of understanding the idea of
molecules understanding the the sort of
foundations of the second law and had
had this very philosophical approach to
to thinking about science and this kind
of idea of thought experiments the idea
that you can figure things out just by
kind of logical reasoning was a very
boltzman type idea which Einstein picked
up on and first of all tried to apply it
to the second law and failed it kind of
had that that strange history but but um
by the time of people like Edington it
was like yep it's true you know we're
sure it's true you know in in textbooks
you know when I was a kid by by sort of
in nowaday I would say one of my
favorite things is some some book that
explains the second law one of the
Mysteries of the second law is that you
can kind of prove this thing called
boltzman's H theorem that says that oh
the entropy will increase with time but
you can take that same proof you can
reverse it and you can say that also
proves the entropy decreases with time
and so there's a well-known textbook
which ends its chapter on this saying
this point is often puzzling to the
student well it was puzzling to
everybody body else as well for about
100 years um and uh we can kind of
unravel how that really works folks I
have to be honest I'm disappointed in
you only 18% of you are actually
subscribed or following the podcast
whether on YouTube or on audio you guys
are listening and watching I know you're
enjoying it but if only 18% of you are
subscribed or following it's going to be
hard to keep getting great guest like
Steven Wolfram so I want you to help me
help you and just hit the Subscribe
button it's free and by doing so it
really help me boost the mission of this
podcast which is to connect millions of
Minds around the world we're doing a
great job but I really need your help to
take this podcast to the next level in
2024 do it now before you forget thanks
so much now back to the episode with
Steven Wolford I would like to go there
I would like to also though I mean I've
had many great conversations including
those with you but you know encoded in
the second law is a is a notion of time
and I wonder if we could start there in
the kind of most most primitive Essence
what how do you conceptualize time or
how how can you define time what is time
what is time and how does it emerge in
in in W from physics I understand not
only time but space emerges so talk us
through what is time so as far as I'm
concerned time is the in exteral
progress of computation if we think
about things in the world as being
governed by rules then what happens in
the course of time
is those rules get applied and that's a
that's a process the the sort of what
the the the thing that changes through
time is that we've applied these rules
more and more and more times and it's
sort of an interesting thing because one
had imagine when one thinks about time
in
mathematics uh usually time is a
parameter in an equation you get some
formula it says you know the planet will
be at this position at this time you can
pick any value for that time you just
dial in the time you say what the answer
is well that's kind of a view of time
that came from sort of the mathematical
way of thinking from a computational way
of thinking it's more you have these
rules and then you run the rules and you
run them this step this step this step
and you see what happens and one of the
important phenomena that I kind of first
started identifying in the 1980s is this
phenomenon of computational
irreducibility this question of when the
computations happen you do this step
this step this step is there a way to
jump ahead is there a way to do what
kind of mathematics says you can do and
just dial in the value of time and say
this is what's going to happen or do you
have to follow every step follow this
sort of irreducible computation to see
what's going to happen and the thing
that was sort of a discovery of mine in
the 1980s is that it's very common to
have systems which are computationally
irreducible where the only way to work
out what will happen in them is just to
run every step and see what happens and
that's kind of the the sense in which
that that process of running the steps
that is the passage of time and it's
sort of an interesting thing that the
computational irreducibility says you
can't cheat the passage of time you
can't jump ahead and say I'm going to
figure out by being a smarter computer
so to speak what's going to happen by
being a smarter brain whatever I can
figure out what's going to happen that
doesn't work there's this sort of
irreducible process you have to go
through that's a limitation on science
in a sense for us feeling good about
ourselves it's it's a big positive
because it means that sort of you have
to live the time so to speak there's no
way to just say the answer to life the
universe everything whatever is 42 or
whatever you you have to actually live
through it to get to the answer there's
no kind of way to Jump Ahead can't
shortcut you cannot shortcut yeah right
it's a it's an irreducible process so
for me kind of time is this
computational process of the the sort of
progression of the universe figuring
applying these rules to see what comes
next so to speak genetic Technologies
including gene therapy and synthetic
biology are surrounded by ethical social
and safety concerns however despite
being controversial they offer promising
opportunities to revolutionize medicine
improve personalized treatment and
Tackle various challenges of human life
so it's essential to stay up to dat with
the latest developments in this exciting
feel for instance recently the FDA
approved the very first treatment to use
the gene editing tool known as crisper
but the media landscape surrounding
these developments is often fragmented
making it hard to find Reliable
information and find a balanced view
which is personally why I love ground
news so much I even deleted the iPhone
news app that's default on my phone and
replaced it with ground news's widget
app and I also bought it for a present
for my older brother Kevin ground news
is an app app and a website that gathers
together all the world's media into one
place so readers can compare coverage
and see the full picture of what's being
reported worldwide for every story you
get a quick visual breakdown of the news
outlets reporting it including their
political bias how factual the source is
which entity owns the source and which
countries are actually reporting and
covering the story for example let's
return to the fda's approval for the
first chrisper treatment right away you
can see that 162 news outlets have
reported on the story of these 162
Outlets 23% lean left 11% lean right and
an overwhelming 66% come from the center
you can even see who owns the outlets
reporting on the story 63% are media
conglomerates ground news also makes it
easy to compare the headlines to see how
the bias might shape and influence the
framing of the story and affect our
understanding of one of my favorite
features of ground news is the blind
spot feed which allows you to see
stories that are underreported by either
side of the political Spectrum ground
news lets you get a deeper understanding
of the complexity and Nuance of
different issues by identifying media
narratives and their biases you can see
every side of the story and thus develop
a well-rounded worldview which is pretty
substantial in these turbulent times you
get access to newspapers and things that
are very hard to find go to ground.
newww dobrian to stay fully informed on
breaking news and compare media coverage
sign up or subscribe through my link for
30% off un limited access if you support
the mission and find it at as essential
as I do to Scientific literacy can
computation occur at zero temperature it
has nothing to do with temperature I
mean temperature is a is an overlay far
above that that kind of issue so
computation is is just the following of
rules that you specify there might be
rules that you could specify for you
know a line of black and white cells you
can talk about temperature let's talk
about temperature for a minute there's a
very different kind of thing so you know
actually it's a very interesting story
because in the in the early 1800s people
knew about heat they knew heat flowed
from hotter bodies to colder bodies and
things like this and they said what is
heat they said well heat must be the you
know it must be like a fluid the only
thing we know that flows as a fluid like
water so they called it caloric caloric
fluid was what was the embodiment of
heat and flowed from sort of a hotter
body to a colder body and temperature
was a sort of characterization of
amounts of was related to sort of this
characterization of how much heat was
there there more or less well so this
theory of what heat was turned out to be
completely wrong because what is heat
heat is the randomized motion of
molecules heat is a feature of the
microscopic structure of matter if if
matter wasn't made of molecules there
wouldn't be heat in the same sense and
so the concept of temperature is a
feature of of a characterization of sort
of the amount of Randomness in these
molecules it's it's it's really the you
know it's just the average energy the
average energy of motion the average
kinetic energy of molecules is just
that's what defines temperature is this
average kinetic energy of molecules that
level of description of talking about
molecules and moving around and so on
the second LW is vastly more General
than that the second LW is a is
essentially a computational statement of
the fact that systems that start simple
to describe will typically become
complicated to describe it's kind of
like encryption you're saying you start
with that that simple uh initial seed
and then you run this thing and you get
something which for all practical
purposes looks random that's what's
happening in these systems it doesn't
have to do with molecules running around
it doesn't have to do with the specifics
of temperature and so on it really is a
is a fair a very basic computational
phenomenon that actually is a
consequence of this phenomenon of
computational irreducibility I do want
to say one thing about temperature and
Heat he and so on which is something you
know close perhaps to your interests so
one of the questions is in uh actually I
should say more about about our Theory
but I want I want to make sure to come
back to this question of caloric fluid
because I have a I'm going to give you
an aphorism okay my my aphorism is is
dark matter is the caloric of our times
and that it will be in the fistin and
the fren phenological approach the
reason I want to say that I brought up
temperature is because as you know in
all the Maxwell relations in the Gibbs
uh Helm Holts um you know enth entropy
uh enthalpy you always have temperature
and entropy interrelated they're coming
in and and derivative Pairs and so the
reason that I'm I'm sort of asking about
that is because it would seem that you
know there is from from things like
louder entropy and and so forth there is
a minimum amount of of of heat is
tangible to a human being unlike uh
entropy which is abstract and and
mathematical it doesn't mean it's any
less real but I guess the question I
have is is you're saying computation is
fundamental and it may be more
fundamental than than even these the
Maxwell relations themselves right it
may be that the the actual operations
themselves which don't have time in them
right they're these kind of abstract
things differentials but I always you
know kind of feel like there's an a
little interloc saying well it's
changing with respect to time the
differential is changing with respect to
time but so it's interesting to say that
it's not necessary to consider
temperature even to have computation
yeah no temperature is a very derived
concept that has to do with energy and
so on the fundamental phenomenon of the
second law has nothing to do with energy
temperature those kinds of things to
talk about entropy entropy is in a sense
a lower level concept so what is entropy
entropy is you know a certain number of
things about a system a certain amount
about a system like you say there are
gas molecules and they're all in this
box and there are a billion of them them
and that's all you know then the
question is well how many possible
configurations of the system could there
be that are consistent with those
constraints that we know and it's a bit
easier to figure that out if you don't
let the gas molecules been in any
position but you just say as as boltzman
actually originally did that it's sort
of quantized uh and that the gas
molecules are just in some grid of
possible positions you just say how many
possible positions are they in oh it may
be you know two to some very big Power
okay so entropy is just the logarithm
the power the exponent there of how many
possible configurations are consistent
with these constraints that you know
about the system that's that's the the
definition of entropy in the original
formulations of entropy it was all kind
of complicated to understand because it
involved continuous variables and you
have to kind of discretize the
continuous variables to figure out
what's happening it's just a
mathematically complicated thing but
this question about does entropy
increase which is sort of the for second
law of Thermodynamics the question is if
you are saying I've got this way of
describing the system and I can describe
it I can sort of immediately say oh I'm
looking at this pattern of molecules and
I can immediately say every molecule is
on an even numbered Square let's say
that's a very sort of short description
now if I let the system run and it's
this irreducible computation happens the
thing that will happen is those
molecules will be sort of
computationally scrambled up
and then we ask the question when we
look at them later can we similarly sort
of say very easily what constraints they
satisfy and the answer will be no in a
sense the configuration of molecules was
encrypted relative to how it started and
it's this phenomenon so the second law
is really a story of the interplay
between computational irreducibility of
these underlying processes and the fact
that when we observe these systems we
are computationally bounded in what we
can notice about these systems if we
were computationally very sophisticated
we could just say about these molecules
well I know and by the way one one
feature of of molecular Dynamics is it's
reversible in the sense that if you see
a collision between two molecules and
you're just seeing that Collision it's
like the Billard balls bounce they
bounce off if you ran that movie In
Reverse it would be an equally valid
movie of the bilad Bulls you know moving
back the way they came and so on at the
level of individual billables at the
level of individual molecules everything
is reversible in that sense and so you
could say well if I know exactly where
all the molecules are then I could just
run this computation in Reverse people
have have concentrated a lot on knowing
where the molecules are it's also
important to be able to compute what
will actually happen when these
molecules sort of do their thing and
have all their collisions and so on and
the point is that to know sort of where
the thing came from you have to be able
to do that computation but that comput
ation is an irreducible computation and
if we as observers of the system are
bounded in the computations we can do we
don't get to be able to do that
irreducible computation so we have to
kind of just throw up our hands and say
what looks random to us and that's
that's why we say it appears that the
entropy increases because we say we
can't decode this sort of encryption we
can't say well actually it came from
this very simple initial condition
that's at the level of of sort of how
things with entropy work when it comes
to dealing with um with with energy for
example in in the case of molecular
Dynamics it's a sort of a separate
overlay and essentially what you're
saying is Well it doesn't just these
these squares that are bouncing around
we're also going to assign a number to
every square and we're going to say that
the energy is conserved when there are
interactions between these squares it's
kind of a slightly higher level of uh uh
of kind of detail that isn't really part
of the core point of the second or of
thermodynamics but it turns out when you
do that you you end up with this
exponential distribution of energies
that um where the scaling for that
exponential is temperature and then you
get the Maxwell distribution and you get
um all the various properties of
statistical mechanics and so on and and
in fact the the uh you know in the end I
mean it's a bit Technical and
mathematical what confused people back
in the day was this when I say back in
the day I mean back in the 1860s 1870s
um was before our time um the uh uh you
know what confused people was there was
sort of an elegant mathematical
structure that James Clerk Maxwell and
other people noticed in connection with
all these different parameters that
define thermodynamics and some people
like actually uh Josiah Willard Gibbs
early American physicist at Yale um was
uh you know his his first big work in
the in the 1870s was um was about about
kind of uh seeing what the consequences
of kind of the mathematical structure
the geometrical structure of the
relations between all these things about
temperature and free energy and entropy
and so on were those are things which
have their own kind of life that are
very relevant for for practical
thermodynamics practical chemical
thermodynamics things like that it's a
separate thing from the foundational
question of kind of how does how do
things end up tending to get more random
and that that doesn't depend on on that
kind of overlay of energy and
temperature and so on yeah no it's more
fundamental I guess the thing that you
know is most striking to me and question
I have for you now is you know could
this have come you know in an alternate
universe could this book have come 30
years ago in other words were there
things that you needed to discover
through the wolf from physics project
through things like the ruad which I
hope we're going to get into and uh and
and and the colonization thereof but uh
could this have been discovered you know
could could Hawking beckenstein could
Gibbs if he were still alive could
Maxwell have discovered what you have
proven in this book in 2023 uh or did it
require the work of the wolf from
physics project in order to instantiate
it into the world I was pretty close to
this book back in the mid 1980s when I
figured out computational irreducibility
I kind of knew that something like this
was there I didn't work out the details
and there was one important piece that
had to do with the role of the Observer
and thinking about the Observer as an
important participant in the cre of
physics so to speak and you know again
to to kind of skip ahead a little bit
the thing that to me is you know we have
these three big theories of 20th century
physics statistical mechanics second law
of Thermodynamics is sort of the big
shining piece of that general relativity
and quantum mechanics and it's always
seemed that well the second law is
almost something you just prove from
pure thought you know general relativity
it's like no you know general relativity
something you kind of have to wheel in
from the outside and say well the
universe happens to work this way
quantum mechanics the same thing the
thing that has been truly remarkable and
that's really emerged in the last couple
of years in the things I've been doing
we've been doing is all three of those
theories of 20th century physics seem to
be
derivable and it's remarkable that laws
of physics could be derivable you know
that was the thing that first got me
really interested in statistical
mechanics that there might be a
fundamental fact about physics that was
somehow derivable rather than merely
something you have to be told that's
kind of the the story and that that idea
that these things might be derivable
that's all sort of come together and
that's been a thing that that made this
kind of this the story of the second law
much more poignant for me much more
something where I where I thought I
could characterize because what happens
is the characterization of the Observer
necessary to derive the second law
general relativity and quantum mechanics
it's the same characterization and so
that gives a that that sort of gives
more strength to saying well I'm going
to pick an observer that works like this
it's kind of like that that's a that's a
bigger pivot point for for that my
audience is used to hearing
interpretations of quantum mechanics but
if I understand correctly you're
essentially saying a classical Theory
like thermodynamics also needs
interpretations and also needs to have a
very well-defined notion of what an
observer is or is not absolutely and and
what you know for
example the fact that the molecules seem
to become more random in their motions
is something that if you were an
observer who could untangle all the
details of how all the molecules work
you wouldn't believe the second law and
actually one of the things kind of
interesting there's this idea of a
Maxwell's demon a kind of little little
cretor that is operating down at the
level of molecules and it's opening and
closing doors and it's doing all the
things that the second world of
thermodynamics says you shouldn't be
able to do of being able to sort of
untangle the randomness and
unweave the randomness right and so one
of the funny things is that if you look
at the physics journals these days
pretty much every week somebody reports
the creation of a Maxwell's demon and
how can that be you know we still
believe in the second law don't we well
what's happening is these are things
which are making doing sensors at the
level of individual molecules and at the
level of small numbers of molecules you
can untangle the second law the second
law isn't true for small numbers of
molecules the second law is a feature of
observers like us who observe these
molecules in a computationally bounded
way on a large scale and so on so the
second law is also a story of the way
that we are observing the universe
rather than just the way the universe is
and and again this the sort of the key
phenomenon is this interplay between
computational irreducibility underneath
and the computational boundedness of us
as observers of that system one of the
things that that uh I would say sort of
a wrong turn in science that kind of
started couple of thousand years ago is
this idea that space is continuous that
you can just put things anywhere you
want in space this is sort of a
foundational idea in uclid for example
the very first postulate a common notion
actually of uclid is a point is that
which has no part that's saying there
are infinitesimal points you can have uh
there's no shortest distance in space
space is just a continuous thing well
now you you run forward in time you get
to the end of the 19th century and uh
people were wondering people were
discovering Quantum Mechanics for
example people were wondering whether
molecules existed the uh sort of the big
question that had existed at that up to
that time was is matter discrete or
continuous that had been argued about
since since ancient Greek times and
people have been you know some people
said oh matter is continuous it's going
everything's like a fluid that's just
going of continuously flow other people
said it's made of molecules well that
didn't get resolved until the first
decade of the 20th century Brown and
motion was the thing that probably
really really uh clinched that that
particular issue you could actually see
under a
microscope uh little pollen grains being
kicked around by by individual water
molecules so that was kind of brown
emotion showed matter was was discrete
then your friend and mine you know
Einstein uh in 1905 basically said well
light is discreet as well that has
photons and so then next thing was
discreet so the next question was is
space discreet and actually I've been
been finding more and more that at that
time for the first 20 years 20 30 years
of the 20th century the typical
physicist believed space was discret and
I'm sorry to interrupt I'm sorry but
people nowadays make uh assertions that
space is discretized including our
friend Elon Musk that there is a
fundamental physics uh attribute called
the plank length which obviously you can
Define it but there's nothing as
fundamental about the plank length as I
understand it as the discretization that
you're going to explain to us correct
yeah I mean the plank length is more a
question of units it's a question of how
you combine you know the different units
that we use to measure you know what do
we mean by time what do we mean by
length relative to time what do we mean
absolutely not fundamental in the way
that you are going to describe okay yeah
please continue right no so so I mean
you know back I think 1916 for example
Einstein had a nice little quote that
said you know in the end space will turn
out to be discret but we don't have the
tools we need to study that yet so 100
years later we do and um uh and so sort
of the the first thing that's sort of a
foundation of of our physics project
from uh from 2020 is uh this idea that
space is in fact discrete and it's made
of things just like you know matter is
made of molecules space is made of atoms
of space atoms of space there's nothing
an atom of space is just a discrete
element there is nothing to say about it
other than that it has a certain
identity that it exists the other thing
you can say is how it's related to other
atoms of space so you can kind of
represent that by this giant kind of
friend network of the atoms of space
this giant Network that says how the
atoms of space are related and so then
it turns out that when we talk about you
know how does how does time operate on
this where we've got this big network of
all these atoms of space and all we know
is how they're related to each other and
then what what's happening is that
there's a rule that gets applied that
says if here's a little configuration of
atoms of space that corresponds to this
collection of relations then it will be
transformed to a collection of atoms of
space with this other collection of
relations it's this sequence of
Transformations between little clumps of
atoms of space and that process you run
that process many many many times and
it's kind of like it's a little bit like
the process of looking at water
molecules you know the water molecules
are colliding and they're they're doing
their thing and on a large scale when
you look at water it flows you can pour
it it's continuous it obeys the
equations of fluid mechanics and so on
but at a small scale it's just a bunch
of molecules bouncing around so you
apply the same thing in the case of
these graphs hyper graphs that are the
relations between the atoms of space you
do the same kind of thing that you do in
fluid mechanics saying well what's the
large scale behavior of such a system
and instead of getting the equations of
fluid mechanics you get the equations of
SpaceTime you get the Einstein equations
for SpaceTime as something which is
derived as the large scale limit of the
Dynamics of these atoms of space there
are a bunch of footnotes to that
statement U among the things that gets
complicated very quickly is this network
that represents atoms of space it's not
in any particular number of Dimensions
it's not like we can say it's a
three-dimensional thing a substrate it's
not a substrate it's not well it is
everything in the universe I mean just
like imagine that the whole world was
made of water and all that we could do
to make sort of persistent things like
us was have little edies in the water
that sort of persist through the water
even though underneath there are a bunch
of kind of uh um sort of uh you know
molecules of water that are bouncing
around for us that the kind of the
concept of our models is there's nothing
in the universe except space and the
features of space are the things that we
notice what might be an Eddie in water
would be an electron in the structure of
space and actually the one thing we we
don't know how electrons work yet in our
models we do know how black holes work
in our models and um so we can we can
make you know we can see how this black
hole exists in the structure of of
SpaceTime and what you see is that space
time space is very dynamic in order for
space to be held together so to speak
it's continually having to get sort of
knitted together by these by these rules
that uh uh that relate different atoms
of space black hole is this region of
space that has this event horizon where
well in the in the formal setup of our
models it's a causal graph that has
certain kinds of disconnection in it but
anyway you can you can set up these
black holes and so for example we just
made a few weeks ago a video of two
little tiny black holes and what happens
in our models and it's pretty neat
because you see kind of that there's
space is bubbling around these are very
very tiny black holes so they're black
holes down at length scales comparable
to the to the elementary length
comparable to the discretization length
for space see these two black holes
they're just there and they feel the
force of gravity so they attract each
other and they come together and they
merge and they produce little
gravitational wave ripples and so far as
we can tell it's a pretty accurate re
rendition of what general relativity
says should happen in fact it's accurate
enough that there are a bunch of groups
that study kind of the numer numerical
versions of the Einstein's equations
that are sort of taking on this model as
far as they're concerned as a way to
think about a discretization of the
Einstein equations so in other words for
them what we've done is we've made this
discrete Network thing which on a large
scale is like the Einstein equations now
normally when they deal with the
Einstein equations they're typically you
know they start with these mathematical
equations and then they usually use our
our product Mathematica to kind of uh
grind through and understand how those
equations are set up and then eventually
they'll get sort of simplified equations
and then they'll say okay now we're
going to put this on a computer but the
way they do those Solutions is to assume
that space is kind of broken at all
pieces just for the sake of the computer
they don't imagine that space really
works that way
for the sake of the computer right and
and but so in our models space really
works that way and what's what's kind of
neat is that our models are actually a
good method for doing numerical General
altivity and that's um so and now the
thing that I find really fun is there's
starting to be some groups using these
and I think for them if there's
something that is a deviation de between
our models and general activity it's
like oh this is really terrible for us
it's like fantastic
now we can see the discreet discreetness
of space and so one of the things that's
pretty interesting is we're starting to
see we're starting to try and tease out
effects that are the the that allow one
to to detect the discreetness of space
so the way one way to put it is Brownian
motion was the thing that clinched it
for molecules we want to find the analog
of Brownian motion for physical space
what is that thing that is some shot
noise and the gravitational radiation
from emerging black hole what is that
difference in the ring down speed when
black holes merge that's associated with
discreetness what's the difference in
the way frame dragging Works around a
black hole associated with discreetness
of space we don't know the length scale
for the discreetness of space just like
people didn't know how big molecules
were so it's a lot smaller than the
plank length we know that um but we
don't know how much smaller and we don't
know uh you know it could be that it's
out of the range of what we can
experimentally detect it's looking like
their effects in for example critical
black holes that are spinning right at
the sort of the limit of how fast they
can they don't actually spin it's just a
parameter in the equations but but um
they they they drag things around as if
they were spinning but um right at the
at the edge uh the the structure of
space is held together by a small number
of of relations in this in this graph
and so if the if the black hole kind of
Spun faster a piece of space would
essentially break off and at that moment
at that point where you have this
critical black hole there is probably a
that's a moment where you kind of have a
gravitational microscope you can start
to see effects that that probe down to
this down to the discreetness length
maybe we don't know exactly how that
works so I just I I can explain my
aphorism about dark matter is the
caloric of our yeah and just to to
refresh the the the viewers or listeners
you know kind of memory I me caloric is
a fictitious property attributed thought
to be attributed to matter that was
storing heat and it's gone to the dust
bin of history now what's interesting
about what you're saying is that uh it
may be uh the the analog of that in the
21st century might be dark matter and we
have abundant you know so so to push
back with respect you know we physicists
are you know debating now between the
various candidates for dark matter it's
not only that dark matter exists we have
abundant evidence for you know from the
CMB anisotropies that I study uh to my
colleagues who look for direct detection
experiments to Galaxy clusters from zi
uh back in Pasadena where you used to
spend some of your time and it goes all
the way through ver Rubin who spent time
here in San Diego so for you to say uh
it's going to rankle some people because
the well let me explain what I mean
because it's there's more to it than
just that that statement okay so
so uh and maybe I should have maybe I
should state it slightly differently for
these purposes but but you know first of
all what is dark matter so you know it's
you see a Galaxy it's got a bunch of
star you know 100 billion stars in it
and there's a certain amount of gravity
that should be associated with all of
those Stars the way gra the Way galaxies
rotate it's as if there's a whole bunch
more gravitational mass than you can see
in the stars in the in the light matter
so to speak of of the stars that are lit
up so there's something there that has a
gravitational effect but is not uh like
a star where you're seeing light and so
on and uh so what do I mean by my
statement caloric was an interpretation
of what heat was nobody was nobody was
disputing you know we still talk about
calories today heat is a thing nobody is
disputing whether heat existed the
question is what was heat and at the
time people assumed that heat was this
kind of fluid that matter was kind of
had had heat inside it there was sort of
a like a fluid that had had worked its
way into the pores of the matter so to
speak to be the heat that was there
because the only thing that was the only
thing people imagine could imagine heat
was turns out what heat actually is is
the microscopic motion of molecules so
now the question is in modern times what
is this thing that produces a
gravitational effect that isn't kind of
like the matter we know well the
immediate thing for people to say is
well the only thing we know is particles
it must be something some kind of
particles so just like people said in
the past heat must be some kind of fluid
because that's the only kind of thing we
know when we're confronted with dark
matter and this thing that happens a
gravitational effect the immediate thing
for people to say is it must be some
some other kind of matter that we've
never seen some kind of you know some
particles you know this kind of particle
that kind of particle I don't think
that's right I think it's actually a
feature of the structure of space just
like it turned out heat was this feature
of the microscopic structure of matter I
suspect dark matter is a feature of the
microscopic structure of space so in
fact and the most ironic thing is that
when you look at the structure of space
in our models there is at the most
microscopic level there's all this
Randomness all this computational
irreducibility all these different sort
of rewrites of this kind of relations
that knit together the structure of
space it's kind of like heat and so it
could turn out to be the case that dark
matter is basically space-time Heat that
it's basically that there exists a a
feature of the structure of SpaceTime
just like heat in matter is these
motional molecules that there's kind of
a space-time analog of that that is
associated with kind of activity in the
structure of these networks that make up
space and so that would be kind of an
ironic thing for it to turn out that um
U that you know it's that what we're
missing is something this exactly it's
just you know science has this habit of
sometimes repeating itself as history
does that um uh that will turn out that
the thing we don't know what an earth it
is is actually something that is a
direct analog of that molecular process
that we saw in matter but now applied to
the atoms of space that are not that are
much more idealized structures than the
kind of molecules atoms that we have in
in matter so you know the challenge so
now the question is okay you're
experimentalist how do you detect this
and uh what can you actually look for
and uh stay tuned because we're trying
to figure this out well I just want to
again you know push back with respect
and and affection but to say that um you
know dark matter doesn't have any
instantiations right now that we
understand very well it wouldn't be true
in other words we know neutrinos are
dark matter they interact weekly they
have a tiny Mass we know what their Mass
bound is we actually are going to
measure that with the Simon Observatory
going to measure turn it from an upper
limit plus a lower limit into a
detection at several uh Sigma and other
experiments as well weak gravitational
lensing will do that and we know of
another candidate that you just
mentioned a few minutes ago black holes
black holes now there may not be enough
of them to make up the critical closure
density but we know two of these things
exist in particulate form and I'm
wondering how uh how would how do you
react to that in other words do we need
another candidate now to explain the
peculiar property
of galaxies and zwiki clusters of
galaxies where he derived it from the
veral theorem why do we need why do we
need to disc GTI space we just need to
find an Axion which we're gonna also
look for um and some of CLA detections
of already so why do we need to do add
in another ingredient into the mix
namely discretization of clumping of
SpaceTime you don't just like you can go
look for features of caloric fluid it
turns out you won't find them I mean
that that's the uh you know this is one
of these things where it is a model
really has well has one parameter which
is the the size of the elementary length
beyond that it has no Freedom there's
you know it whatever it predicts is what
it predicts we're not you know there's
no wiggle room which is not the case in
most current models in particle physics
or something like that it's like oh we
can tune this parameter we can do this
we can do that we don't have any of that
freedom to me what's what's really
exciting about what's happened the last
few years is if you have a model that
has no parameters it's kind of like it's
either right or it's wrong and what's
happened is more and more things have
kind of lined up and yep it explains
that yep it explains that and so on and
so that's very encouraging you know I
don't know yet whether the Dynamics of
our models will lead to a phenomenon
that corresponds to dark matter we don't
know that yet we probably will know that
quite soon it's really a detailed
question doing these simulations and so
on but you know if it does lead to that
then we're just going to say this is
this is what we think is happening I
mean you know and if it turns out it
doesn't lead to that well we're stuck
with axons and things and we have to see
whether we can find those the question
is really is dark matter a clue to a
bigger phenomenon or is it just a detail
of something that is kind of like the
particle physics we already knew and so
on I don't know I mean I I I I I say
that um I I've been very sort of my own
if I were to guess I would guess that
it's something out of left field it's
not a oh you know I mean I used to think
Dark Matter was probably small black
holes and you know then people said oh
no it couldn't possibly be that and etc
etc etc it's gone through I think
neutrinos are not very promising for
that but but in you know different kinds
of uh and it's not we don't know yet
whether our model says you should have a
phenomenon that corresponds to dark
matter but um uh you know I think it is
it is kind of a an interesting thing to
think about and it's it's a I think
there's a certain kind of um I would say
intellectual charm to this idea that the
thing we might be missing is the same
thing that people missed in the 1800s
with respect to the structure of matter
and the nature of heat and and so it's
it's a a um but I mean there are you
know for us one of the things that
happens is there are Dimension
fluctuations in the universe the
universe starts infinite dimensional and
gradually cools down we don't know why
it ends up at three my guess is that the
three is a feature of us as observers
and that we could describe the universe
not as threedimensional it is a feature
of the way that we we are as observers
that makes us think that we should parse
the universe as a threedimensional thing
but in any case the uh but one of the
predictions of our model is that there
will be Dimension fluctuations we don't
know how big but we know that there will
be places where space is not
three-dimensional but it's you know 3.01
dimensional Etc diens and there are
limits there are limits from the similar
phenomena that we discussed earlier
black hole coalesence and also black
hole binary uh neutron star coal
Essences and I want to get back to to
black holes because I think they do
unify your interest in in the second law
and uh and also with gravitational
collapse and the phenomena of Observer
and and system so obviously my my
viewers and listeners are familiar with
things like Hawking radiation
beckenstein entropy and another thing
things I think it would be a treat if we
could if you could kind of work an
example um can you derive you know
Hawking radiation or the beckenstein
entropy for Black Hole from you know
from from these irreducibly
computational uh framework in a way that
we can and and you know note the second
Law's importance uh and as I say a
worked example in sort of words I don't
expect you to have a whiteboard nearby
it wouldn't surprise me if you do but uh
but um can we go through that let's
derve let's talk about uh Hawking
radiation and beckenstein entropy um and
can we get that this is this is okay my
my young collaborator Jonathan gorard
has just been working on this and I
think he has some paper which maybe is
already out or maybe is about to be out
about this exact very topic it's it's a
bit of a complicated story and there are
pieces to it that are a bit alien from
the way people have thought about this
before let me say that to get to hooking
radiation things like that we have to
talk about about quantum mechanics we
didn't talk about quantum mechanics yet
but let me say something even before we
get to Quantum Mechanics let's talk
about the intrinsic entropy of SpaceTime
which is not what one's talking about in
black hole entropy but in this model
where there is a discrete structure of
space time you can say I've got a lump
of SpaceTime and how many different
configurations given that I know that
there's a certain curvature to the space
in this region of of the universe how
many possible configurations are there
of this underly Ling SpaceTime structure
that are consistent with that overall
curvature that's something we've never
been able to address we've never been
able to talk about with traditional
approaches to general relativity and
quantum mechanics we now can talk about
that you can actually start working out
the intrinsic entropy of SpaceTime and
uh given constraints you can say given
these constraints given that we know we
have for example a black hole with
certain uh sort of external metric
external grav gravitational field and so
on we can say well let's actually count
how many possible configurations of
SpaceTime there are consistent with that
that's something we can imagine doing we
haven't successfully done that yet I
think Jonathan has made progress
recently in doing some of those kinds of
things but but let's talk about well
let's talk about it gets a little bit
more complicated when we talk about
quantum mechanics we have to talk about
what quantum mechanics is first of all
but let me say something about about
general relativity and the derivation of
general relativity you've got this
underlying Network it's flopping around
in all kinds of different ways the fact
that we even believe that space is
continuous the fact that we've even had
that idea is a consequence of the way we
are as observers the fact that we don't
say oh space is made of all these atoms
of space we say space seems to us like
it's continuous that's because we're
pretty big compared to the atoms of
space the atoms of space might be you
know 10 to Theus 100 meters apart so to
speak in some sense and we're very big
compared to that and by the way there
are many aspects of the way we par the
universe that are specific detailed
consequen of the way we are as observers
let me give another example so you know
we usually think there is a state of the
universe at successive moments in time
we look around the room we say that's
the state of the room now at a later
time the room will look different Okay
the reason we think that is because as
we look around we're seeing a few tens
of meters away the speed of light is
taking information from tens of M away
to us in microsc but our brains take
milliseconds to update and know what we
saw so it's the fact that the speed of
light relative to our speed of brain
operation is the way it is that makes us
par SpaceTime as there's the complete
structure of space at successive moments
in time so sort of a thought experiment
is imagine that our brains worked a
million times faster imagine we replaced
our neural Hardware with semiconductor
Hardware which runs a million times
faster what would we think about the
structure of space and SpaceTime because
it' be very different we'd be we'd be
continuously seeing sort of the things
that are you know relativistic effects
individual photons we'd be seeing you
know just like we have Echoes from sound
we'd be seeing all these Echoes of light
and so on very different experience and
we wouldn't necessarily piece together
this you know its space at successive
moments in Time same thing if we were
much bigger than we are if we were the
size of the solar system or something
thing we would have very different view
of the relationship of space and time so
the thing to realize is the fact that we
perceive General altivity is a
consequence of the fact that we're
observers of the kind we are and it
turns out that this idea of
computational boundedness we can't
untangle the computational
irreducibility of underlying processes
together with another condition which is
actually also needed in in second law
but it's slightly more subtle the second
condition that we need is that we
believe we are persistent in time and
you might say that's totally obvious
we're obviously we're the same us at the
next moment in time as we were at the
previous moment in time but it's not
obvious because we're made of different
atoms of space at successive moments in
time so the fact that we have this
belief that it's the same us is a
non-trivial thing and that is a feature
of us as observers of the universe that
we believe we have this thread of
experience that continues and so those
two things turn out to inevitably give
us general relativity so the the the the
feature of us as observers the same
features as us as observers that gives
us a second law of Thermodynamics also
gives us general relativity okay so we
should talk about quantum mechanics so
we talked about this this uh Network and
it's all these rewrites are happening
and we say well the network progresses
from this state to this state and so on
but actually there's a little bit more
to it because it's what we say is there
are these rewrites that can happen well
now we can say well just run all
possible rewrites what we'll get is many
different Paths of History there's one
sequence of rewrites that give you this
sequence of states of the universe this
thread of History another sequence of
rewrites that give you another thread of
history and what we end up with is what
we call the multi-way system where
you've got these different threads of
history that are branching and merging
and that's a thing that's that's
continually happening there are
different threads of history that are
branching and merging and it's that
phenomenon that essentially inevitably
gives us quantum mechanics because sort
of the core idea of quantum mechanics is
that it isn't definite things don't
happen in the universe instead there are
many parts of history and we just get to
observe certain probabilities of
different parts having happened and what
what happens in our models is there's
this multi-way graph that represents all
these different parts of history and
then the then the thing is well well why
do we even believe that definite things
happen why do we believe that we have we
we believe that we have a single thread
of experience yet quantum mechanics has
all these different branches that are
that are going so it is an assumption of
us as observers that we can say that we
can aggregate these things into saying
there is a definite thing that happens
very similar to what happens in
thermodynamics where we say there's a
definite pressure to this gas well
pressure from a gas is made up of lots
of little individual molecules you know
hitting our pressure measuring device
and it's the fact that we agre those to
say oh there's just a definite pressure
that's why we believe that there's a
pressure in the gas and the gas obeys
the gas laws and so on so similarly with
respect to Quantum Mechanics the reason
that we believe that definite things
happen is because we are essentially
extended objects in this kind of space
of quantum branches we we talk about
this thing we call branchial space the
space of quantum branches just like we
can talk about physical space as being
the extension of this hypergraph so
similarly in this in this multi-way
graph you can kind of slice the
multi-way graph you get all these
different ends and they have certain
relations that Define kind of another
type of space that has distances between
things that are distances between
different parts of history for the
universe and the the sort of the big
point is that we are extended with
respect to that we are we are in that
system and we are uh we're kind of we're
observing that by aggregating across
many branches of History so that that's
kind of the the very rough idea of how
quantum mechanics emerges now when you
talk about black holes oh sorry Stephen
could be before we go there because I I
think it's a natural point to just break
uh one thing that's always kind of
flabbergasted me is you start with
something in classical mechanics a pound
bracket and you have commutation
relations and exact same language and
Mathematics transmutes exactly over you
know uh into quantum mechanics except
these things are non-vanishing and in
fact they also involve the square root
of negative one um and it's completely
you know almost as mind-blowing a fact
as there is you know uh Fineman used to
say as you knew Fineman personally but
you know that the most remarkable
relation is you know Oilers relation
between e and pi and I and so forth but
this to me is almost even more
remarkable that you get a physical I
mean that's just just in the laws of
mathema I'm not minimizing it
but now you've got this thing in
classical mechanics that ports one to
one except for the square root what what
do you make of this I mean is this
something you know that is just a
fact it's okay so how does that work I I
mean it's always sort of fun because
Vick fan always used to say he' worked
on quantum mechanics his own life his
whole life and he always used to say
nobody understands quantum mechanics and
I I talked to him about that at great
great length Okay it's a shame he isn't
still alive because I think I now
finally am beginning to understand
quantum mechanics and so one question is
like where does the I come from in
quantum mechanics I think it's a I think
it's a confusion actually I think that
one of the things that was sort of a
wrong turn that was taken in studying
SpaceTime actually was what was done not
by Einstein but by minkovski in 1919
when he said oh space and time are
really the same kind of thing let's
packag them together into this thing we
call SpaceTime and he did that makovski
was a number theorist a mathematician
and he said it's very elegant we can
make these quadratic forms that are X
squ for space and t^2 for time and it's
x s minus t^2 it's all very beautiful we
can package together space and time as
being the single space-time thing I
think that was a mistake I think space
is a thing that's very different from
time space is this extension of this
hypergraph time is the inexorable
progress of computation it is an
emergent fact that space and time sort
of work together in the ways that give
relativity that's an emergent fact
that's not something that's built into
the underlying model in quantum
mechanics I think a similar Wrong Turn
was taken so in quantum mechanics one of
the things that one does when formulates
quantum mechanics in terms of wave
functions in the Sher equation or a
whole variety of other other versions of
that formalism what one's doing is one's
saying there are these Quantum
amplitudes there these things that uh we
will be able to represent kind of the
quantum World in terms of and Quantum
amplitudes are complex numbers they have
a magnitude the the the the overall you
know complex numbers can be represented
in in you can sort of plot them in two
dimensions and they have a a distance
from the origin and an angle from the
origin so the the magnitude and the
phase in quantum mechanics One packages
together the magnitude and the phase in
our models they come from completely
different places the magnitude comes
from the counting of the number of paths
in this multi-way system the phase is
basically the position in branchial
space there's a bunch of mathematics we
have not yet worked out and that's quite
difficult I would say but what seems to
be the case is that what's happening is
in quantum mechanics you are you're well
okay so I should say another thing in
SpaceTime one of the key things that
happens is that the presence of energ
momentum or mass deflects shortest paths
so as you know very well the um there
are geodisc paths shortest paths in
SpaceTime and you know when you just are
dealing with everything on a plane for
example the shortest path between two
points is a straight line if you distort
that plane the shortest path between two
points won't be a straight line anymore
and the kind of original idea of general
relativity was the structure of
SpaceTime is being distorted by the Pres
pres of mass and that Distortion is
causing shortest paths to no longer be
straight lines shortest paths are
deflected and that's the deflection
associated with the force of gravity and
that was kind of that's kind of the the
basic idea of general altivity and so
what happens in our models is well you
can have shortest paths same kind of
deal in this graph you can just say
what's the shortest path on the graph
going through edges of the graph how do
you get from this place to that place
going through the smallest number of
edges on the graph so now you can say
well the next question is what's energy
momentum this is something really
surprised me actually I thought it was
going to be very difficult to understand
what energy momentum is turns out it's
not turns out energy momentum is
essentially just the amount the density
of activity in the network so we've got
all this network is being Rewritten in
all these different ways we can
represent that slightly more formally by
a causal graph that says there these
little rewrite events and every rewrite
event can is producing out output that
will be the input to subsequent rewrite
events and we can make this graph that
represents the the sort of causal
connections between these things and
energy is simply if we look at well we
have to Define in in relativity as you
well know we're talking about space-like
hypersurfaces these things so so events
can be related in a Tim likee way in the
sense that one event is uh followed by
another event in a sequence in time
but there are also events that can be
space likee separated where those events
can happen simultaneously in time if
you're Tim like separated you better not
be space-like separated because one
event is follows from another event and
they couldn't be simultaneous but there
are events that are sort of orthogonal
to the the timik directions or
space-like directions there are many
different choices of space likee
directions that what's what gives the
reference frames and relativity and so
on but in any case if you look at these
spacelike hypersurfaces energy in our
models is simply the flux of these
causal edges through space-like
hypersurfaces momentum is flux through
Tim like hypersurfaces okay so then you
can derive the presence of the existence
of gravity and you can derive the fact
that there is when there is this density
of activity in the network it deflects
shortest Parts in the network that's a
pretty neat thing that you can give an
intuitive definition uh
intuitive happens right yeah so actually
to give another one of these intuitive
things so time dilation is a phenomenon
of of special relativity that you know
things that are going fast uh things
that are moving a lot time seems to go
slower for them well in our models you
can kind of see why that happens because
what is time time is this inexorable
process of executing
computations motion is you get to recre
create yourself at a different place in
space that that phenomenon of motion the
fact that you're recreating yourself at
a different place in space that takes
computational effort so you know that
have this tradeoff what are you going to
spend your computational effort on
you're going to spend your computational
effort on moving in space or you're
going to use it on progressing in time
and so when you're moving in space
you're using up your computation on
motion so you don't have as much left
over to prog in time so that means you
effectively time goes slower for you and
that's what time dilation comes from and
and the math works out and that's that's
really how it works and and it's it's
really quite to me it's really amazing
that you can give what is essentially a
mechanistic explanation of what seemed
to be a purely kind of the math happens
to work out that way kind of phenomenon
but okay so that's how this works in in
physical space in branchial space
there's a similar phenomenon you have
these jd6 these shortest paths things
travel on shortest paths but now energy
momentum also deflects shortest paths in
branchial space and then what's the
consequence of that well it's there's
this there something is is is is
deflecting shortest paths and it's
moving where you are in branchial Space
the fundamental law of quantum mechanics
one way to State it is the fan path
integral the F and path integral says
you have this thing that is what's
called the action kind of this
relativistically invariant version of
energy um and that the presence of
action effectively energy momentum is
the thing that changes the phase of your
of the of your description of the
quantum system so in other words the
presence of energy momentum is making
this change so in our models the
presence of energy momentum is
deflecting jd6 it's moving things but
it's moving things not in physical space
but in branchial space so now the
question is what what is motion in
branchial space well motion and
branchial space appears to be change of
quantum phase and so what's happening is
what in the the phenomenon that is
general relativity that is deflection
due to gravity in physical space that
same phenomenon the deflection in
bronchial space is a change of quantum
phase and that change of quantum phase
is what the path integral says should
happen in quantum mechanics so in other
words what one's saying is quantum
mechanics is the same phenomenon as
gravity and general relativity what is
general relativity in physical space is
quantum mechanics in bronal space
they're the same thing does that imply
it's a simplec geometrical that
bronchial space is also simplec uh space
in other words that's manifold uh it's
essentially an abstract manifold on
which these things can take take place
or am I misinterpreting that so it's a
little complicated because momentum is
this Flux Of causal edges through time
like hypersurfaces and so when you look
at a a commutation relation that's about
uh this Flux Of causal edges as compared
to position I don't know the answer it's
quite possible that it's it's not
mathematically trivial to figure that
out um it it uh an interesting question
about these commutators and anti-
commutators is the presence of you know
there two very different kinds of
particles bosons and Fons uh things like
photons where you can cram as many
photons as you want into something they
really like to hang out together which
is why lasers work or electrons but they
really don't like to hang out together
you can only get one electron in a given
State and that's why you know matter
doesn't collapse and things like this
and that's that's um and so this
distinction between Fons and bosons is
the distinction between commutators and
anticommutator and quantum mechanics and
it looks like there is in these
multi-way graphs it looks like we don't
know exactly how this works but it looks
like there is a relationship between
kind of the the structure of these
multi-way graphs and whether when you
have a branch in the multi-way graph it
immediately recombines or not that
that's related to the presence of that
that the the branching and recombining
is a commutator being equal to zero and
so the uh um it seems like bons are that
case and firion are the case where
things sort of tree out and don't
recombine how that relates to the
simplec structure in uh in Phase space
let me think about that for a second we
should come back to it maybe in a in a
separate conversation at a later time
but um uh because I think it's
imperative for me as an experimental
physicist you know I'd be I'd be uh
shirking my duties if I if I didn't ask
about some consequences that my
colleagues potentially can investigate
you know not not on your behalf but on
our behalf right because these could be
pointing in New Directions newer
interpretations but also new physical
observables so we talked a lot about
black bodies we talked a lot about the
second law we talked about ter so I
studied the CNB the most perfect black
body known to exist in the universe um
there are aspects of it that can be used
to synchronize clocks or to synchronize
uh coordinate systems within our local
frame of motion which is caused by our
Dark Matter driven at least in some
conceptions motion towards the Virgo
supercluster so my question for you is
are there observables are there
distortions say there common spectral
distortions to a black body that are I
wouldn't say easy to observe I mean it's
not exactly what I do but the
Technology's been there for for some
time to measure very minute parts per
million parts per hundreds of a million
distortions to black bodies are there
are there kind of quaries that you can
set me and my colleagues off on to look
for that would lead to an interpretation
or perhaps a measurement of some
fundamental link scale computational we
think so we don't yet know I mean this
is this is one of the challenges is you
have a fundamental Theory and you have
to build up from that to something you
can actually point a telescope there and
see it I mean you know cautionary tale
from General activity that you probably
know well is uh you know the the one of
the predictions of general relativity is
that the bending of light
around the sun will be twice as great as
it was in the in the Newtonian theory in
1916 so the theory was proposed in 1915
in December of 1915 in 1916 there was a
total eclipse uh was visible from Crimea
and um uh there was a Expedition that
went to go and observe where light was
bent more around the Sun than it would
have otherwise been at that time well at
that point Einstein had calculated it
wrong so he had a prediction and these
guys went to go and measur the
prediction and they almost measured it
except the US centered World War I and
these American physicists with all their
equipment were told by the Russians I
guess at that time no you know this is
off limits go away oh they they imprison
them yeah that's right so so the
experiment didn't get done then your
friend Edington in 1919 went to South
Africa redid the experiment I suspect he
cooked the books on that experiment but
that's a different issue and by that
time Einstein had corrected the the
calculation of the bending of light
around the Sun and Edington claimed to
have observed exactly that phenomenon so
you know it is a difficult thing to go
from the fundamental physics to an
experimental prediction I've seen this I
I used to do particle physics where one
could uh at the in the late 1970s which
was a very golden age for particle
physics and I saw this multiple times of
you know for example one of my
experiences in as a young physicist when
I was 17 years old actually was I I
worked out in qcd theory of quarks and
gluons how many charm particles should
be produced in proton proton collisions
so I had this calculation I said the
number should be this okay there was an
experiment that said no it's not that
the number is is 10 times small is less
than 10 times smaller than that and it's
like what's going on I didn't know what
to do so I published this paper where I
said this is the calculation from qcd
and then half the paper is but the
experiment says it isn't true here's why
it might be wrong even though qcd really
said that's how it should work well
turns out the experiment was wrong that
was the last time I didn't visit an
experiment whose uh you know after that
time I always made it a principle I'm
going to go visit the experiment going
to ask all kinds of questions I'm going
to you know it was a was one of these
experiments where they're looking for
something where they didn't find
anything and that's always suspicious
because you know when you find nothing
it's kind of you don't really know that
you were looking to trying to detect it
correctly but so so you know with that
cautionary statements what kinds of
things might one look for well I think
the the um you know I think Dimension
fluctuations are a big thing I think
that um there are a bunch of um bunch of
effects actually it was just um uh my
young colleague Jonathan gorad was just
at a a um uh um gravitational wave
background conference and um I think and
some other people there cooked up a
whole bunch of things that are possible
effects that you could look for um The
Challenge in all of these is just doing
the physics that goes between this very
small length scale so for example one
really cool effect would be
gravitational lensing around the
dimension fluctuation so in ordinary
gravitational lensing you know you're
you're looking at some Galaxy or
something and the light is being bent by
the presence of of uh of mass um in this
case we expect that the light will be
bent by the presence of a dimension
fluctuation if if if the universe isn't
exactly three-dimensional then the the
kind of the uh you know if you even have
the electric field from a point charge
usually just streams out in all
directions and has an inverse Square law
kind of um uh fall off but if you're not
in three dimensions it's not an inverse
Square law and there's a there's an
effective there's an effective kind of
refractive index type thing that seems
to happen when you go through a
dimension fluctuation so the the coolest
experiment which I don't think is going
to work out this way but it would be
super cool if it did is that we don't
know how this works yet we don't know
what actually happens to a bundle of
photons that go through a a dimension
fluctuation but you know in in a very
fanciful way one could imagine they're
shattered into some kind of fractal
distribution uh in the Imaging plane and
then the the the thing that would be
spectacular which which I think is very
fanciful so far is we'd be able to say
use the Space Telescope you look at this
thing you've got this thing that looks
like noise you make this transform on it
and you got a picture of a galaxy if
that happened we really know we're
seeing Dimension fluctuations I don't
think it's going to be as simple as that
I think that the the likelihood is in
terms of CMB um I think the the
potential is Relic Dimension
fluctuations from the early universe and
the question is what are their
signatures and you know in our models
there's no inflation Story the reason
that different parts of the universe are
in causal contact is because the
universe was originally infinite
dimensional where causal contact is
Trivial because the the you know the
different parts of the graph everything
is connected to everything so so then
what happens so there are no doubt
predictions about actually that that
brings up something very concrete
Stephen because if we on the Simons
Observatory or our competitor and bicep
and others if we detect a primordial gas
of gravitational waves resulting from
primordial curvature pertubations and
fluctuations in the inflaton that would
seem to falsify this at least the notion
as I understand it of of of the infinite
dimensional space cleaving into a finite
number of Dimensions so it's virtue of
what you're saying because it's
falsifiable in the paparian sense is it
not the calculation of what the
gravitational wave spectrum is from um
you know our models is a difficult thing
I mean hasn't yet been done we don't
know how to do that yet we we've there's
no there's no inflaton there's nothing
to fluctuate there's no Multiverse right
in in your model no that's that's right
but but there will be there will be
gravit there will absolutely be Relic
gravitational waves from the beginning
of the universe right but their Spectrum
would be probably very different from
what inflation would predict in other
words I'm looking for is a big messy
Story I mean inflation has a thousand
well not a thous but at least 20
parameters that you can tweak we don't
have those parameters so whatever we
predict we're stuck with predicting that
we don't know what I would encourage you
I would encourage you at Great haste
Stephen because this is something that
over a billion dollars is being planned
devoted to in the field of cosmic
microwave background so-called B mode
experiments that are not only looking
for the presence of these primordial
gravitational but eventually they're
power Spectrum if indeed they exist now
if we discover them and you know in
other words it's a crisp test it's a
decisive test to use Popper's language
uh but Stephen I I have to go put some
kids to bed in about 10 minutes but I
have a billion more questions to ask you
I'd love it if you would beg beg your
forbearance to have a part two at some
part four at some time but I do have
some questions from the audience that
they're dying to ask you yes please so
okay these will be uh maybe yes or no or
quick short answers so we can get
through as many I'm really bad at short
answers I
apolog I haven't noticed Ste I never
noticed okay so you mentioned according
to uh my listener sh sha Shader uh Steph
mentioned that he had realized ads CFT
is related to do with something to do
with bronchial space can you give any
details or implications about so what
happens is that and again the details
are not fully known yet but this is not
a yes no question
okay okay in the simplest way of
thinking about it every branch in the
multi-way graph has a complete Universe
has a complete state of the universe
but that's a very inefficient way to
think about it rather those states of
the universe most aspects of them are
the same it's only a small part that's
different so you end up you end up with
this thing we call multi-way causal
graph that relates the different events
that happen at different places in
physical space and on different branches
in this multi-way graph and you've got
this multi-way causal graph that
contains information both on the
relationship between events at different
places in space and the events at
different places in branchial space it's
the fact that there is a single object
that contains information about both
branchial space which is related to
quantum mechanics and physical space
that's related to general relativity
that's what knits those two things
together and so the adfc of key
correspondence is almost certainly two
different projections of this multi-way
causal graph a projection in the
branchial direction giving you the CFT
part a projection in the in the space
spatial Direction giving you the the ads
part and again there's the bunch of
people have been working on this and um
it's uh uh you know that that seems to
be what's going on that's the intuition
about what's going on U you know there's
this ER equals epr kind of conjecture
that comes out of ads CFT which it looks
like we can reproduce in our models but
there are many details to be filled in I
mean this is a you know what what what's
happened with these models basically is
there's a big burst of activity in
physics 100 years ago lots of of things
got figured out there's a certain
Paradigm that existed in mathematical
physics at that time we kind of have a
new paradigm and there's a lot of new
stuff that could be figured out but it's
complicated and it's it's going to take
you know it's going to take the work of
lots of people and some time to know all
these consequences but we we've you know
kind of the way we see it is it looks
like we've really you know we know how
the machine code works now we kind of
have to see what the consequences of
that are hey guys I'm so sorry to
interrupt this amazing deep with my
friend stepen wolam but I know that
you're going to want to catch this
special offer that I make once a month I
select a winner of one of you out there
to win a piece of space dust a real 4.3
billion year old Space Rock just
visiting my website Brian king.com and
by joining my mailing let's you get the
freshest space news and access to my
guest I always send out information so
you guys can communicate with great
guests just like Steven wolferman ask
him questions as you saw that we did on
this episode so do it now now before you
forget go to bring.com list if you're
not already subscribed and join the
mailing list and every Monday you'll get
the most magical message delivered
straight to your inbox okay now back to
the episode so this is a question I'm
going to kind of pervert it to my
purposes but uh someone named uh G Tyro
uh maybe uh asked the question of your
thoughts on the future of Science in the
age of llms and I want to augment that
Stephen with my host prerogative by uh
stating a fact that you're probably
aware of uh you do you recall what
Einstein's happiest thought was that
gave him palpitations Stephen do you
remember what Einstein said the fact
that the universe is is is
understandable to us is is remarkable I
mean that not that one I'll give you a
hint there's old Albert okay what was
here's Albert he's in freef Fall he's in
freef Fall okay so an observer in freef
Fall experiences no gravitational force
I want to use that as a springboard to
ask you about about Ai and and it's
potential as a scientist uh to do
scientific uh for us as scientists but
to generate new scientific ideas and the
way I like to say it is can a computer
have a happiest thought like Albert and
can it do science the way he did without
a body without the sensation of what it
means to freef fall perhaps in a
visceral sense are you optimistic that
there'll be an AI Galileo or AI e you
know Einstein to what extent are you
optimistic or pessimistic about
scientist scientific breakthroughs
coming from AIS and L well this is a
complicated story The the basic thing is
in the computational universe of all
possible computations there's lots of
stuff that goes on only some tiny sliver
of it is stuff that we humans care about
there's only some tiny sliver of it that
we even have sensory apparatus to detect
and so we've you know we've pulled out
these things that we care about that are
the the the aspects of the universe the
natural laws that we want to talk about
in the universe there's a lot more
besides so the challenge is not to go
out and find natural laws it's kind of
like in mathematics we can go out and
generate theorems I wrote this whole
book about the physicalization of metam
mathematics about you know in US humans
we've written down about three or four
million theorems in the history of
mathematics but there's an infinite
number of possible theorems you can just
go out and generate them you can have a
computer go generate all these theorems
the issue is which of these theorem are
we humans going to care about and this
question of sort of what is there to
discover there's a there's a big piece
to that which is there are all these
prongs we can we can kind of pursue
there all these directions we can pursue
which ones are ones that that sort of uh
kind of merge with the narratives that
we humans care about so this question
about uh what does it mean for you know
i' I've spent large part of my life
trying to formalize the world in
computational terms and that's what our
computational language W language that
you know millions of people use every
day uh is all about it's about kind of
you know we had these different kinds of
formalization we used human language to
formalize things we could say you know
the concept of a rock rather than
individually pointing at every Rock we
have logic that kind of you know sort of
gives us the structure of arguments
independent of individual arguments we
have mathematics gives us a type of
formalization computation is I think a
much more powerful type of formalization
that is the defining kind of
paradigmatic idea of our Century
actually and I think that uh the kind of
that's kind of the big the big thing is
can you represent the world
computationally and then the question of
in which direction do you want to go
this this comp this thing you can
represent computationally has lots of
directions lots of richness the question
of which way you want to go is really a
much more human question did we do we
this is a long story I mean I've I've
I've uh I've I've talked about written
about a lot this this these kinds of
issues I think this is a um uh you know
bottom line sort of uh you know in a
sense people would have said a lot of
the things I built in my life a sort of
AI doing science but this question about
you know do you just say okay AI I want
to detect features of the of the cosmic
microwave background you know tell me
what experiment I should build tell me
what um uh those are things where if you
define your objectives carefully enough
then there is a chance that you can
search for solutions to you know I've
got this engineering problem I want to
have this particular strut that you know
is is organized in this way and is is
you know minimum weight or whatever else
and you know you can absolutely imagine
computationally kind of searching the
set of possibilities and finding the one
that works I think there's much more to
say about this I mean there's there's
some and actually I'm I'm currently
doing some experiments that have to do
with the question of just what can
things like llms predict you know they
do a good job of predicting uh sort of
what you might say in an essay to follow
what is typical of what has been said in
the essays on on a few billion web pages
and the question would be in the natural
world to what extent can an llm predict
things that happen in the natural world
there's no reason they should be able to
for example an llm trained on human
natural language I don't think it's
going to do it we actually just in fact
I probably get right after this to see
the results of one of those experiments
we've been training some llms llm like
technology to to make predictions of
idealized natural systems and trying to
understand uh to what extent to my guess
about what's going to happen this is a
very dangerous thing in doing science
because I have a guess about what's
going to happen but I've been doing
science long enough to know that the
most one of the most important things is
not to take your guesses that seriously
because the chips are going to fall as
they fall and you have to be ready for
that and it's a mistake you know
scientists make this mistake all the
time you have a hypothesis and you just
keep going doing things until you verify
that hypothesis and you know that's you
have to not do that so but I'm going to
tell you what I think is going to happen
and then I'll go look at my computer and
it will have not happened so that that's
um the humility yeah right no it's an
important feature of of um you know I
think it's it's it's critical if you
actually want to get the science right I
mean it's kind of um um you know but I
think the what I think is going to
happen is that it's going to be possible
to predict things that when we as humans
look at them we say oh yeah I know how
that's going to continue as soon as
you're hitting kind of computational ir
reducibility and as soon as you can't
tell as a human what's going to happen
the AI is going to fail as well we'll
see if if if we're chatting again in
another episode you can ask me about
that again and I'll tell you what the
answer was I would love that and I I
just to just to reiterate how grateful I
am for your time and staying up late and
I want you to get to look at those
experiments and I got to put some little
experiments to bed but we got through
about two of the 11 pages of notes and
questions that I had so I'll beg your
forbearance in the New Year perhaps uh
to do a a part four because uh there's
there's so much deep interest in what
you're doing and you know from a venol
self-interested perspective too I want
to know what you know possible ways to
prospect in the CMB sky and in the
underground particle accelerators so
forth that my colleagues and I can do to
get a deeper a deeper glimpse into the
nature of reality I want that too we're
we're you know the problem is we're
building a bridge from two sides right
we have an underlying Theory you have
experimental equipment that can measure
things and now it's a question of we got
to you know in the end we've got to in
the end there's a lot of physics work of
building that bridge and you know I
think that's uh we're we're kind of just
trying to get that started and uh you
know I I might uh I might Grill you for
information about um the details of
you'll know that we're getting close
when I'm grilling you for information
about your detectors and exactly what
they can detect and so on but we're not
yet there I'm not I'm not yet ready for
that no I more than happy to oblig and
and I have brilliant students that can
assist but yeah I've been thinking about
we need sort of a Rosetta Stone you know
to transmit between the language of
mathematics the wolf from Alfa language
and uh the the physics project the
theoretical space we need to map that to
the hardcore Observer space because
that's what I love to do and uh there's
nothing more fun than making a decisive
measurement so Stephen uh W from Dr
Steven wford thank you so much for
sharing your time I hope uh the
experiments that you're running tonight
will bring you great Joy but also allow
you to get some sleep whenever it is
that you turn in turn in for the evening
thank you so much Stephen have a great
rest of your year and I'll be in touch
in early uh early next year and we'll
hopefully do another part sounds good